ciao a tutti i ragazzi sono tornata con
un ennesimo stupidissimo ora gentaglia
ciao a tutti amici sono 224 ci sono un
momento in cui ciao a tutti e benvenuti
a questa nuova puntata di mike bello a
tutti ragazze benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo in un
nuovo proprio prima di cominciare come
si dovrebbe partire con la fanar della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da ci aveva un nome stranissimo
come cazzo si chiamava aspetta da keynes
che ha fatto questo bisogno che è strano
nel senso che mi dà molto l'area di
[Musica]
però prima di vincere che l'invito
ragazzi devo farmi vedere assolutamente
una cosa che è successa questa settimana
che praticamente ha davanti un altro il
programma quello di bonolis che va bene
hanno fatto una domanda su di me ve la
faccio vedere perché devo analizzare con
voi delle cose stato il partecipante che
ha risposto alla domanda è per questo
signore che dei baffi somiglia vagamente
al maestro di kung fu panda che non so
perché da un po di tempo su internet
girano i video di un giovane umano che
non giova né umano grazie mi ha detto di
tutto questo ancora no pro grazie paolo
da quanto pare questi video piacciono
tantissimo agli umani suoi coetanei
tanto che il ragazzino è diventato in
poco per agazzi
a vent'anni perché mi nonno del
ragazzino vi prego lo capisco che se non
ho la parma sembra che io abbia 12 anni
ma in realtà ne ho venti porca [ __ ]
stato in poco tempo una vera e propria
star come si fa chiamare questo
fortunatissimo fanciullo con un
fanciullo che vedono la difesa spaak man
superori j
io mi ragazzi mi fermerei a super lori
pro chi è il genio che ha scritto su
perché olio conosce quello che ha fatto
la puntata e l'epicità fatta nickname
la cosa ancora più strana è che il
ragazzone coi baffi che avete visto
prima è un contadinello come mika passa
per chi sono gli oggetti impossibile
[Musica]
va beh la cosa che mi è che apprezzo
maggiormente di tutto questo è che non
hanno scritto faringe colagè in staccata
porca vacca che goduria a parte questo
ragazzi durante la settimana sono uscito
con i miei amici mi è capitata una
serata però è andata così male ma non è
che se crede serrano
[Musica]
lo ha detto ragazzi che questa cosa l'ho
scoperta da pochissimo che i miei
genitori hanno instagram giuro non lo
sapevo da qualche fan non mi ricordo chi
adesso bello che non ho visto il profilo
di instagram dei miei non l'ho ancora
visto apposta perché voglio vederlo in
diretta la vogliono che cazzo mettono
dentro c'è da quanto cesso profilo mia
madre fatemi capire cos'è cos'è
adesso capisco cosa fanno i miei quando
stanno a casa e io che pensavo peggio
mica preso mille like più di mille la
una foto di mia madre mi prendo io mille
line sei molto carina ma questa è [ __ ]
mio padre che viene con gli occhi chiusi
nelle foto è bellissimo il profilo di il
profilo di mio padre si chiama on
ps vorrei capire perchè onyx che casa in
pokémon a ecco questo è questo e beck è
stata ricordo mio padre si becca i big
like bakayoko bakayoko è la cosa strana
è che a dio la foto non ha ricordato bar
icarly lo spaghetto adesso vi abbiam
capito che i miei genitori possono
smetterla di fare quello che fanno e
fare i fashion blogger nonché le foto
dove vengo io in genere siano più belle
c'è mio dio questa sembra chiesto
consolando qualcuno del tipo se la vita
è ingiusta a come sono contento dice
questi baci sono proprio un acquisto
godendo non si vede per quanto riguarda
il fa vi risponde ragazzi nello scorso
blog vi ho chiesto scrivete al posto la
domanda è sorta delle sfide non che
siano tipo mangiati lo yogurt a testa in
giù e ovviamente quale poteva essere la
prima sfida di oggi suicidi quindi
lasciamo perdere le sfide foto e sega
più 90 arriva da alessia vederti fare la
barba acquistare
allora io ho fatto il post un posto del
recentemente su facebook aveva messo
questa foto dio che mi faccio la barba
però voi tutti sapete che io non ho la
barba me la sono fatta senza motivo
scrivendo perché a farsi la barba senza
avere la barba è il modo giusto per
sentirsi veri uomini dealessi appunto
scritto viretti fare la barba è un po
come vedere club
bisio dal parrucchiere è bellissimo
perché hai azzeccato l'esempio perfetto
brava brava non so cosa mi ha fatto
godere di più se non questo commento o
il fatto che abbiano scritto fa vige in
modo giusto davanti un altro una delle
due una delle sfide tra l'altro che
c'erano era detta da pk jk westin
complimenti per il nick name e anche per
la foto extra di sfida di a tua mamma
che hai messo incinta una ragazza
registra la sua reazione non lo farò ma
la cosa che voglio chiedervi me lo sono
visto chiedere da un miliardo di persone
cioè io sta cosa va l'ho letta un
miliardo di volte mi avete chiesto tutti
da secoli perché lucas moreira ma casa
tua non la re di più in realtà da quando
l'ho fatta vedere devo ancora arredarle
tutto era vuota era veramente vuota
quindi abbiamo fatto dei cambiamenti con
i miei genitori mi hanno aiutato un
sacco e vi faccio vedere una cosa che è
stranissimo preso la prendi abiti della
metropolitana che tipo ci sono i casi
della metro c'è anche un minion è bello
se incastrato da loro tanto c'è ancora
la pizza che ho mangiato prima perché io
sono una persona ordinata la cosa che ho
preso è stata al televisore per questa
cosa che insomma che non ci stava perché
se nostri cosi di merda a chi ne ha
messi il tra casa di morta acceso il
televisore sporta dalla mensola quindi
tipo mikado a dopodomani è conclusa le
domande direi che possiamo passare allo
scarto dei pacchi se vi chiedete come
faccio ad avere i pacchi visto che sono
nella mia casa è perchè me li sono
portati da torino vecchi vecchissimi su
un pacco c'è scritto buona pasqua allora
ragazzi ne hanno solo due di quattordio
niente anche con due cazzo di bach è
riuscita a cader menù non è però solo
due ragazzi che va dentro solo due
perché ne ho portati cinque da torino
quindi almeno tre me li tengo per i
prossimi blog facciamo devono azionarli
a primi durante un tuo video buona
pasqua buona pasqua anche a voi ragazzi
buona pasqua a tutti i pavimenti qua
dentro ci trovo la tomba di famiglia è
perfetto oddio ci credo c'è un po di
pasqua grandissimo e non è neanche
scaduto secondo me
e non ricicliamo nel senso lo tengo per
questa pasqua così non davo marco andare
a comprare luogo complimenti per la
scelta del luogo e my little pony grazie
ma ancora d'amato delle barbie mi danno
da ragazzino mi danno le giovane
fanciullo a cristo almeno dei regali da
maschio o la nutella che più che è
scaduta mi sembra un reperto storico è
signore e signori ultimo ma non per
importanza un numero di di una tipa con
le tette che apprezzo al prossimo parigi
non siete stupendi ogni volta di più fa
favi panino ciò le uova cioè i panini da
mangiare sono poi uno slider man senza
senza niente male se ho trovato la testa
ha trovato la testa noi siamo già post
sacco di cose madonna che pacco enorme
non pensate male nella foto di miley
cyrus photoshoppata poster che bello
adiyiah dietro c'è justin bieber degli
occhiali bellissimi complimenti per la
scelta e vedo lo schermo nel mio
riflesso abbiamo come ultimo un parco
nel pacco quindicenne è ancora un altro
quindi sono tre alla fine l'ultimo parco
ragazzi ci stanno dei o dio caramelle se
la madonna la loro hit ella questa nuova
grazie ai ragazzi che un clan che lo
scarta regioni pacchi che da un secolo
che non facevo perché roba ma che rocky
disaster in poster di miley cyrus sul
mio letto cosa penserà mia madre
prendi conclude ragazzi come al solito
passa da fare domanda di oggi la fabi
domanda di oggi ex come questa è anche
casa vostra
perché mi dite un pezzo di arredamento
anche ridicolo tipo che ne so le lampade
di miley cyrus da mettere da qualche
parte in casa mia così che io quando
guardo quel pezzo dell'arredamento mi
ricordo come l'avete detto voi così
avete personalizzato a casa mia se mi
viene in mente un pezzo anche ridicolo
ripeto di arredamento che io possa
mettere in giro magari non un letto
sadomaso o forse sì concludo più
l'episodio ragazzi cosa e se vi è
piaciuto momento è un mi piace anche a
faccia di facebook e come nei video tra
tale iscrizione senza vestiti 33 cv
diavolo conseguiti beh ragazzi